PROFESSOR: So some of
the standard questions
that we've examined
already about random graphs
are the probability of getting
from one place to another,
or the expected time to get
from one place to another.
But a different kind
of question that
comes up in a fundamental
way is the probability
of being someplace.
So let's examine that.
Here is the graph with states
blue, orange, and green
that we've seen before.
And suppose that I
start at state B.
And I ask, what's the
probability of being at each
of these states after one step?
So to start with, I'm
interested in p B, p O,
and p G-- which is the
probability of being at state
B, the probability
of being at state O,
and the probability
of being at state
G. The sum of the
probabilities is going to be 1.
And initially when I tell
you that I'm at state B,
it means the probability
of being at B is 1,
and the other two is 0.
And I'm interested in the
way that these probabilities
update after one step.
If p prime B is the
probability of being in state B
after one step, and p
prime O is the probability
of being in the orange state
one step later-- and likewise
for green-- what are
these probabilities?
Well it's easy to see just
reading off this graph
that the only place you're
at is B. So the only way
to get probability
of being somewhere
is by following
an edge out of B.
So the probability of being at
one step at the orange vertex
is 1/4.
And it's likewise 1/4 for
being at the green state.
And it's 1/2 for staying
at the blue state.
So what we can say is that
the updated probabilities
of being at these
different states
is 1/2, 1/4, and 1/4,
as we've just reasoned.
OK.
Let's keep going.
Given that the probability
that I'm at the states blue,
orange, and green are given by
this vector of probabilities,
what's the distribution
after two steps?
So let p double-prime B be the
probability of being at state B
after two steps,
starting from B. Well,
the way we can
figure that out is
by using conditional
probabilities.
Let's look at the
example of calculating
the probability of being
in the orange state two
steps after you've
started at the blue state.
So here was the probabilities
of being at the different states
after one step.
How do I get to
the orange state?
Well I can get to the orange
state from the blue state.
And so the probability of
being in the orange state
after two steps
is the probability
of being at the blue state after
one step times the probability
that I take this edge
to the orange state.
That is, it's the probability
of going from B to O-- given
that I'm at B-- times
the probability of being
in B after one step.
This then is the probability
of being in O after two steps.
And likewise, another
component of the probability
of being at O is that if
you're at O, and what's
the probability of
going from O to O?
And that is this 1/3
times the probability
of being at O at
all, which is 1/4.
And the final case, using again
the law of total probability,
breaking it up into cases,
the third way that I
can get to the orange
state on step two
is by being at the green
state on step one following
the green to O edge-- of
which there isn't any,
so that's going
to be probability
0-- times the probability of
being at the green state, which
is 1/4, but it won't matter.
So let's just fill
in these amounts
looking at the first term.
The probability of going
from B to O when you're at B
is simply the
probability of this edge.
It's 1/4.
And likewise, the
probability of going from O
to O given that you're
at O is the probability
of this edge-- namely 1/3.
So we can fill that term in.
And finally the probability
of going from G to O
is 0, given that you're
at G, because there
isn't any vertex there.
And then you fill in
those probabilities
and do the arithmetic.
You come out with
5/24 probability
of being in the orange
state after two steps.
Well the same calculation,
you can figure out
what's the probability of
being at the blue state
or the green step
after two steps.
And there's the answer.
There's a 50/50 chance of
being at the blue state
after two steps, 5/24 as
we saw at the orange state,
and the rest of it is
7/24 is the probability
of being at the green state.
OK.
So what's going on in general?
And we can explain how to do
these calculations by using
a little bit of linear algebra.
So let's define the
edge probability
matrix of a random
walk graph is just
the adjacency
matrix of the graph,
except that instead of using
0's and 1's to indicate
whether an edge is not
present or present,
I'll use in the I, J
position of the matrix--
the probability of the edge
that goes from I to J--
if there is an edge-- and
0 if there isn't any edge.
Let's look at an example.
So here is the way we'd
fill it in abstractly
for our three-state graph.
It'll be a 3 by 3 matrix
with the probabilities
of the successive edges in
the corresponding position.
So this is the
position in the B,
B coordinate is the probability
of the edge from B to B. The O,
B coordinate, if you
think of the columns
as labeled blue, orange,
green; and the rows as labeled
blue, orange, green.
And this is the orange,
blue coordinate.
And it's the probability
of the edge from 0 to B.
Let's fill in the first
row, which was-- this
is just read directly
off the graph.
It was the edges out of
B that went from B to B,
from B to O, and
from B to green-- G.
And it had those weights.
And if I fill in
the rest of it, I
get the edge
probability matrix for
our simple three-state graph.
And there it is.
So this last one shows the fact
that there is a certain edge
from green to blue.
The only place you can
go from green is to blue,
and you can't go to either
orange or green in one step.
OK.
So why are we bringing
up the matrix?
Well if you looked at the
way we updated the state
to go from the
one-step distribution
to the two-step distribution,
it was really a matrix multiply.
And in general, to
do an update, you're
just going to do a vector
matrix multiplication.
If you have the probabilities of
being in the successive states
B, O, and G, and you do a vector
matrix multiplication using
the probability
matrix of the graph,
you get the updated
vector of distributions.
And that's easy to check
just from the definitions,
and from the definition
of vector times matrix,
which I assume
you're familiar with.
So now we can ask what's the
distribution after t steps,
starting from some particular
given distribution-- say,
starting at state B, or starting
at any possible distribution
of probabilities to
the different states.
And the way that we can
figure that out-- so I'm
interested in other
words is the probability
of being in O after t
steps G after t steps in B
after t steps, say,
starting from state B.
And what happens also as
t approaches infinity?
And these are sort of
two basic questions
that we're going to be asking.
So first of all,
how do you calculate
starting at a given
distribution p
B, p O, p G where you're
going to be after t steps?
Well, you're just
continually updating, which
means multiplying by M t times.
So the distribution
after t steps
is gotten by taking the
initial distribution times
the t-th power of M.
Now this is actually already
useful computationally,
because it means that since
you can compute a matrix
power by successive
squarings, you actually
only need about log of
t matrix multiplications
in order to be
able to figure out
what's the distribution
of probabilities
after t steps of the graph.
Then the crucial concept
that we want to examine--
and we'll make a lot of use
of in the next video when
we talk about a page
rank-- is the idea
of a stationary distribution.
So a stationary
distribution means
that once you're in the
stationary distribution,
it's stable.
You're going to stay
in that distribution.
You're not going to be
in any particular state,
but you'll have a vector
of probabilities of being
in the different states.
And one step later, that
vector's not going to change.
So what it means is that
the next-step distribution
is the same as the
current distribution.
What's the stationary
distribution here?
Well, the way we're going
to have to calculate
that is here's how you update.
This is the result of the
vector matrix multiplication.
But let's just spell
it out in terms
of the conditional
probabilities.
After one step, if the
original distribution
is p B, p O, p G, then
the new probability
of being in state
B, the only way
you can get there is by
following the edge from B
to B with probability 1/2.
And that's times the
probability of being at B.
And the other way
you can get to B
is by being at the green state.
And then one step later
you're certain to be at B. So
that adds a contribution
of 1 times p G.
And likewise for p-- the
updated probability of being
at the orange state
and the green state.
And what we want is that
these updated probabilities
are the same as the ones
that I'm starting with.
That's the definition
of stability.
You update the
vector p B, p O, p G,
and you get the same vector.
That's what makes it stable.
And of course, a
side constraint.
Since you can always solve a
system of equations like this
by letting all the p's be
0, which is degenerate,
we add the constraint
that the sum
of the probabilities of being
in the states has to be 1.
Well if we solve that simple
3 by 3 system of equations,
then it turns out that the
stable distribution is there's
an 8/15 chance of
being in state B,
a 3/15 chance of
being in state orange,
and a 4/15 chance of
being in state green.
And you should
check that yourself
by asking what's the probability
of being in p B after one step
given these probabilities?
And I'm not going to
talk you through that.
But just to verify and
imprint the idea of stability,
that's one that's worth
stopping the video for a moment
to check and do a little
arithmetic with a pencil
and paper.
OK.
So in general, what
we're going to do
is we're trying to find
the stationary distribution
vector-- call it
s bar, for vector.
And we get this by solving
the vector matrix equation--
that the distribution vector
times the edge probability
matrix is equal to that
same distribution vector.
We want to solve this
system of equations.
If there are n
states, then this is
an n by n system of equations,
with an additional constraint
that we want the norm of
the stable vector to be 1,
because that's to avoid
the degenerate 0 solution.
Well there are some problems
with stationary distributions
that we want to think about.
First of all, what happens in
this example where you have
just two states, and
the probability of being
in the first state at 1
and the second state is 0?
Well if you update that
state, what happens
is you just go to the second
state with probability 1.
And you can keep doing that.
And there may be a
stable distribution here,
but this particular pattern
doesn't converge to it.
As you go through time,
at every other step
you're at state 1, and every
other step you're at state 0.
But you never get to
a stable distribution
where step after step you
are at equal probability
of being at these two places.
I'm assuming here that
this is a certain edge,
and that's a certain edge.
It has to be.
There's only one edge out.
So a stable distribution
would be 1/2, 1/2.
But this thing doesn't
converge to it.
OK.
Here's a slightly more
complicated example,
where again assume that all
the edges are equally likely.
There's exactly two edges
out of each of these vertices
so that each edge
has weight 1/2.
And the problem
with this graph is
that when you ask what's
the stable distribution
and, well, if you look
at it, if you assume
that the probability of
being in the middle is 0,
and the two places that you
get stuck at have probability p
and 1 minus p,
then that's stable,
because once you're at this
state with probability p
you're following the one certain
edge that goes back around
to this vertex.
And therefore
there's probability
of p of being there
one step later,
and likewise probability
q of one step later.
So the split between p and
q is a stable distribution
for this thing, with
probability 0 and 0 there.
And of course p and q can be any
real numbers between 0 and 1.
So there's actually
an uncountable number
of stable distributions
for this graph.
Problem here is it's
not strongly connected.
And that turns out to be
a sufficient condition
that it's got a single
stable distribution whenever
it's strongly connected.
So in general we can
ask the question,
is there always a
stationary distribution
for any random graph? well,
if the graph is finite, yes,
there's guaranteed to be
a stationary distribution.
But is it unique?
Well sometimes, sometimes not.
If the graph is strongly
connected, it will be unique.
But we've seen examples
in the previous slide
where it's not unique.
In fact, it could
be uncountably many.
And another crucial question
is, does a random walk
approach the stable distribution
no matter how you start?
And that first
example was one where
you went between the first
state and the second state
and oscillated.
And it never converged on
the stable distribution
of 1/2 and 1/2.
In general, it's nice when
you can say that no matter
how you start, after a
while things stabilize,
and you wind up at the
unique stable distribution.
So sometimes it'll be the case
that every initial distribution
will eventually converge
on the stable one
or the stationary one.
Sometimes not.
And then another
crucial question
will be, how quickly does
this convergence happen?
If we start off at some
arbitrary probability
distribution, or some
particular state,
how long does it take
before by and large
the probabilities that were
in the different states
has become pretty stationary?
And the rate at which
that happens again
varies depending on the graph.